Speaker 1: All right. Let's hear from a few more
people when we take calls. We do so via discord.
You can find our discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. Let's go to Ben from San Angelo.
Ben, welcome to the show.
Speaker 2: Hello?
Speaker 1: Can you hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: Okay. Great. Now, I have a question to
ask you about the U.S. presidency. Okay. Are
you familiar with the C-SPAN's presidential
historian survey?
Speaker 1: No.
Speaker 4: Okay. Well, I really like it. It
was last updated in 2021. It asks about 140
different, I guess, historians, what they thought
about the presidents. And I guess my question is.
Do you think that using the survey here is a good
way to sort of talk to others about, you know,
presidents and the really bad
presidents versus the really good ones?
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I'm looking at
it now. And just to give people context,
basically, historians rank the presidents and
Lincoln basically is always number one. George
Washington goes between two and three. FDR
goes between three and two. Teddy Roosevelt is
almost always in fourth. When you look at recent
presidents, Barack Obama was ranked, I guess it's
like around 10th. Trump is ranked fourth to the
worst. The only people ranked worse than Trump
per historians are Franklin Pierce, Andrew Johnson
and James Buchanan. Here's the thing. I think this
is interesting, but if you try to tell someone
who's like some kind of Trumpist or right winger
about it, they'd go, The historians are just left
wing shills and they'll just ignore it, you know?
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 4: That was my question. But thank you.
Speaker 1: Oh, no problem. Yeah. I mean,
I hate to be, like, kind of cynical, but
if they don't like what it says, they'll just
say it's not worth listening to, you know? No.
All right. Okay. Well, he left. I guess maybe
my answer was not. Not not suitable. That's okay